i just found out that i do have corona
i have been in my room
it's gonna be fine but it was
really bad for a couple days
khloe kardashian is one of the millions
of americans who have tested positive
for the coronavirus
let me tell you that sh
is real but we're all going to get
through this
the 36 year old reality star revealed
that she tested positive for covid19
this past
spring and documented her experience on
keeping up with the kardashians
she's so sick and that really scares me
for her because i can tell
that she's now getting scared and that
she's really nervous about it
i of course then jumped on the phone
with every doctor who would take my call
trying to find somebody that could help
her i just found out that i do have
corona coco details her symptoms and
says it's
unlike anything she's ever experienced
it was
[Music]
really bad for a couple days
vomiting and shaking and
hot and then cold and i suffer from
migraines but this was the craziest
headache i wouldn't say was a migraine
you can hear it in chloe's voice this
virus
is no joke the coughing my chest would
burn when i would cough
and i mean i still my throat is still
not fully recovered clearly let me tell
you
that is real but
we're all gonna get through this praying
if we follow orders and listen we're all
gonna be okay
thankfully chloe has seemingly fully
recovered in fact
she recently attended kim's 40th
birthday getaway on a private island
we had fun a source previously told et
that the birthday girl brought her
family and friends to an island on
private planes where kim shared these
sexy bikini snaps
proving age ain't nothing but a number
kim's hubby kanye west
and almost all of kim's sisters were in
tow
courtney chloe and kendall but kylie
stayed back
she was spotted deboarding a plane with
travis scott
and their two-year-old daughter stormi
earlier this week
a source tells et the youngest
kardashian jenner sibling
couldn't attend the b-day fun because
she had
work commitments she works really hard
you